i never thought in my wildest dreams  that i would be here  when they announced this movie i was  like really really excited kind of  tongue-in-cheek i ended up tweeting  marvel hey are we going to talk or what  so i'm very glad i did that shanxxi the  legend of the ten rings  [Applause]  we shot this film in sydney over the  course of like 13 months  some days at work are harder than others  this is every kid's dream  [Applause]  a couple of people to say hi to you  it totally was a whirlwind experience  going from city to city  [Music]  seeing the way that the fans responded  it was such an incredible moment for all  of us  this is only the beginning it's time to  show them who i really am  [Music]